au happy days au happy days salut pour
que ce jour est un jour applique je vais
arrêter de chanter et je vous parle
aujourd'hui
dupilet
[Musique]
le pdc le jour où l'on célèbre pin ans
ne fuyez pas rester ici veux juste vous
dire des choses intéressantes sur pie
que peut-être vous ne savez pas encore
et à la fin de la vidéo je vous donnerai
également une dernière conclusion par
rapport aux deux vidéos qui est juste
week-end c'était pas non plus un gramme
à 2 14 mars est donc le genre de pi le
pida parce que autant en france on écrit
14 mars 14 03 autant outre atlantique
ils décrivent à l'envers donc 03 14 3 14
piles et la première journée vraiment
dédié à pied a eu lieu en 1988 à
l'explorateur y sommes j'ai pas trouvé
d'image exacte de cette première fois
mais la représentation que j'en ai lu et
marrante puisque tout le personnel et
public marché en cercle pour célébrer
pis tout en mangeant des tartes des
pailles en anglais
le pire c'est que ça m'aurait plu de
faire ce genre de délire alors il ya
toujours des tartes maintenant aux pies
d'helaba l'explorateur hiram mais depuis
ils ont également été des bides et pis
c'est tout et le fondateur du pidc l'art
y show un ancien physicien qui a
retraité à l'heure d'aujourd'hui mais
qui s'occupe toujours de l'événement
chaque année alors pisser quoi papier on
le connaît pas ce que c'est le nombre
par lequel il faut multiplier le
diamètre d'un cercle pour connaître la
circonférence du même cercle d'ailleurs
l'appellation pi n'a pas été choisie au
hasard puisque peas et la première
lettre du mot grec qui signifie
périmètre et ce nombre-là cette
constante la a toujours fasciné tout le
monde de même 2000 ans avant
jésus-christ les mathématiciens
s'intéressait déjà appuyé et avait déjà
constaté que c'était pas un nombreux
ronds et pour le calcul et à l'époque il
utilisait un principe géométriques qui
consistait à construire deux polygones
réguliers ayant le même nombre de côté à
l'intérieur du cercle à l'extérieur du
cercle et il cherchait comme ça un
encadrement de la valeur de pique donc
en construisant des hexagones des
polygones à assise côté comme quand on
encadre la france on trouve que pied
compris entre 3 et 3,47 et c'est archi
métier en moins de 150 avant
jésus-christ a fait ce calcul a avec des
polygones de 96 côté il a trouvé environ
22 7e soit 3,14 18 c'est pas si mal
quand même
on est en moi 250 revanche si les gars
bon alors on l'a déjà dit sur cette
chaîne pis c'est un nombre irrationnel
ça veut dire que sa suite de décimales
et non répétitive et surtout infinie et
depuis archimède on continue d'essayer
de calculer le plus précisément possible
puis et là on pourrait dire qu'avec
l'arrivée des ordinateurs c'était hyper
facile d'avoir des milliards et des
milliards de décimales
c'est seulement en 1949 que les n'y a
qu'a utilisé pour la première fois un
ordinateur pour pour des fins comme ça
de recherche publique et ils sont
arrivés à 2037 décimales seulement je
dis seulement pour aujourd'hui parce que
pour l'époque c'était énorme
c'était une précision énorme est-ce que
j'ai bien dit que c'était énorme et
c'est seulement en 1973 que si les
décimales avaient été des abonnés pays
aurait reçu son trophée
puisqu'en 73 on a passé le cap du
million de décimales de pi calculé
autant dire que dalle
par rapport à l'infini et le 17 octobre
2011 après 3 171 jours non-stop de
calcul par les ordinateurs
on a passé le cap des 10 milliards de
décimales de pi
alors là on pourrait se dire qu'on
s'approche d'une valeur plutôt pas mal
par rapport à notre 3,14
non pas qu'un c'était 18 à l'époque
d'archimède mais pourtant encore une
fois du milliard par rapport à l'infini
sait rien ou si on peut comme ça
continuer à rechercher ces décimales il
ya donc des trucs amusants à faire avec
pee wee je te jure pas que la prendre
comme je l'avais fait dans la vidéo qui
est juste ici avec un pote as de pique
alors comme on pressent que c'est un
nombre univers ça voudrait dire que dans
ces décimales on pourrait trouver
n'avoir quelle séquence de chiffres
défini sur le site andy au point est que
vous retrouverez dans la description je
vous met vous pouvez chercher c'est
votre prénom il est dans pi alors pour
trouver votre prénom tant pis pour
remplacer chaque lettre par sa position
dans l'alphabet pour moi le f2 fabien c6
le ac 1 le bc 2 et bien cette suite là
elle existe tant pis
j'ai donc mon prénom quelque part dans
pis j'aurais pu aussi chercher fabian
lui qui a répliqué aurait pu chercher
fabien olicard suivi de ma date de
naissance ou fabien olicard suivi de ma
date de naissance et de mon nombre
d'abonnés aujourd'hui il existe
forcément un endroit dans pis on
trouvera ça mais est ce que cette
séquence là existent entre 0 et 10
milliards ça j'en suis pas encore
certain
faudrait rechercher sursis on peut
également s'amuser à faire des
représentations physique de pi alors il
ya des magnifiques posters qui existent
ou yapi de dessiner avec ses propres
décimales je pense qu'un de ces jours je
vous remets train là quelques pas parce
que je kiffe bien ça je vous mets le
lien également dans la description si
vous regarder de très près c'est tout
les décimales de pi qui sont marqués
tout les décimales qui tiennent dans le
poster il ya aussi des grands malades
mentaux qui ont fait une représentation
de 4 millions de pixels correspondant
aux quatre premiers me
lyon deux décimales de pi ça aussi c'est
vrai je vous met à lire dans la
description ils ont juste décidé de 0 à
9 d'un code couleur un code couleur
prend 0,1 pour un poids de l'état et ils
en ont fait une représentation comme ça
visuelle alors là je vous parle du pid
et du 14 mars mais il ya une date toute
aussi importante en tout cas pour
michael hart depuis 2010 il essaye de
faire valider le jour de tose le 28 juin
donc le 6 28 et non pas le 3 14
c'est ce qu'on appelle le jumeau
maléfique de pi selon lui on considère
que pi est faux alors non pas dans dans
cette définition ça allait juste
mathématiquement parlant mais parce que
on considère plus souvent à certains
son rayon qu'à son diamètre donc la
constante est plus ou moins définie par
une circonférence / un rayon soit 2 pi
et dans papy ou alors pipi mais je
voulais absolument éviter cette veine
dans cette vidéo et ces pop a légué un
mathématicien qui en 2001 a donné
l'appellation de deux pitots et voudrait
lui aussi qu'on remplace pipart tôt et
pour terminer avec une chose d'original
qu'on peut encore faire avec pi en
utilisant les décimales de pi ya
quelqu'un qui a essayé de mettre en
musique pis ça c'est intéressant il a
pris ton que les premières décimales
donc 3,5 atteint 5,9 de 6 5 3 5 8 9 7 9
3 2 3 et ses réserves pour en faire une
représentation musicale je voulais un
court extrait juste ici mais je vous
mets surtout le lien de cette vidéo qui
existe sur youtube donc je vais pas lui
prendre non plus à sa vidéo je vous
invite si vous voulez la voir en entier
à la regarder
[Musique]
à
je trouve ça très étonnant est encore
une fois très mélodieux alors c'est à
dire qu'on peut écouter pis on peut voir
pis on peut faire aussi de l'antique y
avait bien une journée pour vous parler
de tout ça c'était aujourd'hui en ce
jour du pilote pour terminer avec ce qui
s'est passé sur les vidéos de samedi à
dimanche si vous les avez pas vu je
recommande de regarder peut-être pour
commencer la vidéo de dimanche vous
allez mieux comprendre
encore une fois c'était pas une vidéo
agressif quand elle c'était un constat
de ma part un constat d'échec
je sais qu'on a beaucoup qui ont dit oui
mais par rapport aux taux là ils disent
là que tu te focalises sur sur beaucoup
de commentaires alors ça c'est aussi un
problème de communauté silencieuse dont
je fais partie c'est à dire je laisse
souvent des lay par contre je laisse
assez peu de commentaires il va ça
laisse le champ libre à des trucs comme
il s'est passé samedi je garde la
décision pour l'instant de ne pas
refaire ce style-là de vidéos sauf si
j'arrive à analyser où sont mes erreurs
et elle leur faire en fonction parce que
même si nous les créateurs ont fait des
vidéos pour nous ok ça on est d'accord
on fait ce qui nous plaît sur youtube
fut promis à prenez ça mais néanmoins je
fais partie de ceux qui lisent vraiment
tous les commentaires et quand 9
commentaires sur 10 disent la même chose
ou on la même teneur en agressivité ou
disent même truc a été corrigé par un
poste épinglé en fait non t'as pas envie
de leur faire même si c'est quelque
chose qui plaît mais j'avais quand même
envie d'utiliser le droit de réponse qui
est ma propre chaîne évidemment puisque
répondre dans les commentaires moi même
ça ne suffisait pas puisque le code
n'était pas lui en question vous pouvez
par contre leaké cette vidéo que vous
fassiez partie de la communauté active
ou silencieuse
vous pouvez aussi laisser un commentaire
pour me dire ce que vous avez pensé tout
ça et là encore une fois je m'adresse à
la communauté active et la communauté
pas silencieuse hashtag pas silencieuse
ça va être chaud ne vous lâche tech de
cette chaîne je veux le voir partout
vous pouvez le mettre partout vous
voulez sur le net hashtag ne soyez plus
silencieux pas silencieux les mecs
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner et rendez
vous très bientôt je pense que ça va
être samedi matin à 11h ciao